it's an absolute mess uh given what
we've been hearing from this latest
report um from the
health committee cross party committee
what has boris johnson done during his
tenure to try to ease the problems in
the national health service well we've
been
going through a record number of
recruitment processes for
doctors for nurses also for other public
servants like police officers for
example
but of course what we are seeing is that
the inflationary pressures which are
affecting all of us are particularly
affecting those people in public service
that's why it's so important that
whoever steps in
as prime minister next and i hope that
it is liz
will get a grip of inflation start
driving down inflation so that people
can keep more of the money that they can
earn more people can feel comfortable
staying
in the nhs
and that we can address both the uh the
external pressures that are affecting
the nhs like uh inflation but also some
of the long-term demographic changes
which are increasing pressure as well
yeah but money is no good to you if
you're sick and there isn't a doctor to
look after you i was speaking to jeremy
hunt in the last hour and he was
suggesting that we should ease border
controls for some doctors and other
healthcare workers to get them into the
uk until we've trained those that we
need
well we have always relied my mother was
a midwife she came from sierra leone so
we've always relied on medical
professionals from overseas that's not
going to change and actually part of
leaving the european union and having a
much greater control over our own
immigration policy is that we can adjust
immigration to make sure that we have
the right
mix of people high skilled people like
medical professionals whether they be
doctors or nurses or or
other specialist roles and we are doing
that
we are we also have to make sure we
train um
british people to go into those medical
professions as well yeah i'm talking
about uh borders what on earth is
happening uh down at the port
whose fault is that
well uh
i think liz was absolutely right when
she said that the pressures ultimately
can only be resolved on the french side
it seems that they don't have enough
people on
to man the checks we have always had
border checks anyone that's crossed
into france will know that we've always
had checks at the border we're not part
of the schengen area so but they've been
waved through most people with the odd
passport being checked well and there's
a place anymore and there's every reason
that that could continue because as i
say we've we've not been part of the
schengen area so we've never been
part of the uh uh the passport-free
european area so there have always been
checks um the fact that they are taking
so much longer now
is causing these problems that can and
should be resolved liz has been speaking
with her opposite number in france about
this very issue i know grant shouts has
been speaking with his opposite number
in the transport uh department in france
so we are working to get this resolved
but ultimately this is something that we
do need um the french authorities to
increase the number of people doing
those checks so is it the fault of the
french
well
what i want to do is look to resolve
this issue well i say what i want to i'm
no longer your minister i'm education
secretary but ultimately i think the
priority is to get this resolved and to
make sure that we don't do anything to
make it worse and i think the best way
of doing that is to work with
our french counterparts rather than
getting into a kind of place spending 21
hours in the in the car with the kids
with you know only a small bottle of
water is that taking back control
well as i say we have always had checks
at the border so you're implying this is
a brexit related issue
where you get waved through and every
now and seldom they would check a
passport now of course we're not part of
the european union anymore and as a
result they're checking every passport
no no no that's that's a non-sequestered
if you haven't been through that border
you have never have you ever driven
through that border absolutely so you
know that you've gone through without
your passport being checked but we've
always been sorry we have never been
part of the schengen area there have
always there has always been the
necessity for border checks how those
checks are done should and could be
pragmatic because we are no greater risk
now than we were when we remember state
of the european union prior to uh 2019.
so um i i i would fracture entitlement
to protect their borders as much as we
are and as i say and we are not suddenly
at greater risk than we were when we
remember states of the eu okay uh talk
to me about um liz trust your
candidate's suggestion that she would
scrap the increase in national insurance
straight away that would
lose 12 billion pounds that has been um
earmarked for social care and the nhs
and that would be scrapped what impact
would that have on
staffing and waiting lists in the nhs
and also for social care so what liz has
said is that we need to go for a
economic growth strategy and increasing
the tax burden on businesses which are
inevitably going to be passed on to
consumers is not the way of doing that
we are already highly taxed as a society
and i think when there are inflationary
pressures when prices are going up what
we need to do is to make sure we reduce
the bit of people's expenditure that we
are in direct control of and that is tax
so it's absolutely right that we allow
people to keep more of the money they
have earned
that money will help them uh uh meet the
increasing bills that that we are all
seeing that's absolutely the right thing
to do it will also give an economic
boost and she's also gone to gone on to
explain
how we'd have these uh light regulatory
zones to boost uh regional economic
growth across the the uk
that's how you do it by getting more
money overall in the economy it means
that uh the individual pressure on
families is reduced but there's also
plenty of money coming into the
exchequer to pay for those public
services like the nhs that we've just
discussed how much respect do you have
for the office of budget responsibility
well of course we listen to it of course
we listen to it but ultimately it's
madness but ultimately
it's the decision of politicians which
are then implemented by officials it
shouldn't be the other way around it
should not be officials telling
politicians at what they should and
should not do policy-wise and the simple
fact is you look around the
international they're not doing that
they're suffering look around if you
look around
the other major economies like uh like
ourselves
nobody else is going for a taxation
level that we are at at the moment so
of course tax income is important that's
what pays for those public services but
the best way of maximizing the amount of
money you can spend on public services
is maximizing the growth in the economy
and that's what lizard said she's uh
planning to how much respect do you have
for the economist patrick minford who
your candidate has mentioned a couple of
times hasn't she yes she has okay do you
have respect for him yeah of course he's
here he's a he is a well-respected um uh
economist but like all economists he
gives advice um but ultimately
it comes back to the same point whether
it's from officials whether it's from
economists they give their ideas they
give their advice but ultimately it's
for politicians to make the decisions on
this he would see an interest rate of
something like seven percent what sort
of impact would that have on people's
mortgages
well
with the uh we're seeing globally these
inflationary pressures this is a global
phenomenon it doesn't help people all
then you can't pay them all and we are
seeing in many parts of the world that
interest rates uh are nudging upwards
now we have had a very very very long
period of very very low interest rates
now uh for for you know the last best
part of 10 years it's been it's been
close to zero interest rates it was
always
um it was always it was never going to
be possible to keep them that low in
debt
be acceptable well uh ultimately we want
to keep interest rates uh modest we want
to make sure that
save us well look i'm i'm not an
economist uh but ultimately i'm sure
a big jump in interest rates will hit
people who are um already finding bills
difficult and that's not what we want to
see but ultimately what we need to do is
make sure that we have an economic boost
and again
it keeps coming back to the same point
that
the the way
sustainably you address these pressures
that we're seeing from
the you know fuel price increases food
increases uh in part because of the
invasion of ukraine is to make sure we
get uh increased level of economic
activity that's the point that liz has
put a couple seven percent acceptable
that's not what i've said no i'm asking
you well we will of course we wouldn't
want to see seven percent five percent
look i'm not gonna start i'm not gonna
start uh this is the sort of thing that
that conservative grassroots uh people
want to know voters want to know when
before they put their ex on the box
there is no no there is no prime
minister
that can absolutely cast iron guarantee
what interest rates will be in the
future
if you have tax decreases interest rates
will have to go up well the point is
that tax decreases will stimulate uh
economic growth that has got to be the
only if you earn enough to pay taxes
that is what is going to be the
foundation stone of any other economic
policy it's got to be growth first if
your economy isn't growing
everything else you might want to
discuss is about how you mitigate bad
news a growing economy gives the
opportunities for good news a shrinking
economy is only bad news that's why liz
is going for a growth strategy thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of tory party members want
boris johnson back should he get a
senior role in government
well uh do you support that well i'm not
the one running for uh for the
leadership i know so boris uh i've i've
worked him for years you know i
supported him i continue to regard him
as an incredible effective uh politician
it's so he should have a relationship
it's not for me it's not for me to start
uh suggesting he wouldn't be discontent
if he was in government well he's an
incredibly talented politician uh
whether he would want to serve after the
bruising that he's got at the moment
that might be another matter but it's
not for me to start dictating to liz who
she puts into her cabinet but you would
welcome him if he did come back well i'd
be comfortable if she is okay um just
before we let you go how's your mrs
doing she's doing well yeah i know you
and i do genuinely appreciate the the
support that you give and a lot of other
people give
she's she's heading in the right
direction um these hot nights are not
always the most comfortable when you're
recovering from surgery but the the
prognosis is positive the doctor is
happy oh well we send her much love
thank you very much for joining us thank
you